[Musique]
je suis devant la politique intérieure
que se faisait attendre
en fait je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'on
connaît la politique c'est surtout qu
est ce qu on voit par exemple dans les
médias qu'est ce qu'on lit dans les
journaux que je me suis dit être sur
place voir aussi question en coulisses
ça serait vraiment intéressante pour y
circuler
oui pourquoi bourgault faut pas dire ça
ses amis on valorise beaucoup une
éthique de travail donc voir qu'est ce
qui est important c'est la neutralité
l'impartialité votre local c'est pas
grâce à la can au salon veut évidemment
la première chose c'est qu'on va venir
monter les coûts donc pour les greffiers
ensuite on va aussi ce qui fait de la
documentation de cannes pour préparer la
séance de l'assemblée nationale voilà
mario titre on sait qu'on a notre
équipement de travail reste revenu c'est
juste ici autre à côté du leader
évidemment évidemment en période de
questions mieux en effet pour les faits
ce que vous voyez sur le côté donc on
ait eu des pages qui sont là puis on va
se préparer à répondre à ces tout
derniers les pratiques et les députés
vont devoir se passer exactement il est
délicate a chipé cycle où les gens
d'ailleurs dit rendements du papier
portant denis pour répondre à une
question donc c'est nous qui font le
lien entre l'extérieur et l'intérieur de
la fin un député peut écrire une note
sur un papier mais on sait jamais ce qui
est écrit sur ces papiers là et parfois
on peut voir les politiciens ce fusil du
regard avoir un si petit à petit et il
arrive parfois donc j'aimerais que dans
le vin ggd question quiz pour jour
encore caisse députés
oh mon dieu non ces problèmes avec un
député est ce que vous êtes formés en
conséquence pour pouvoir dénonciation et
on a aussi beaucoup de bosses aux jeux
c'est quelque chose que par exemple jean
qui n'a pas eu d'autres avant même
d'avoir pu nous entendre on veut cacher
leur nom il ya des dictatures n leroux
sanglant c'est une particularité de vous
rend possible de voir tout ce qui se
passe non dans la mesure où qu'on voit
qu'il ya plus de travail qui sait en
amont et en aval dans lequel j'ai vu le
côté moyens qui pour moi c'est vraiment
un bel ajout là à l'expérience en
général
[Musique]